hallo leute werben heute besuch aus
polen woher kommt ihr wäre kommen
gymnasiums ecoshopper und was machen wir
heute
wir sprechen über den buchstaben g das
ist richtig denn das geht wird im
deutschen manchmal unterschiedlich
ausgesprochen und wir finden heute raus
wie los geht's
[Musik]
können sie mir sagen wie dieses wort
ausgesprochen wird groß groß groß groß
können sie eine satz mit dem world
bilden
ich bin groß weg weg der weg die wege
der weg die wege der weg die wege können
sie einen satz mit diesem wort gliedern
der weg ist sehr lang wohin geht der weg
dies ist der weg das sind die wege der
weg dorthin ist nicht so weit
die wege des herrn sind unergründlich
ich kenne den weg der tag der tag der
tag der tag das ist der tag von uns
derzeit zu ende
richtig richtig richtig das ding das
ding das ding das ding ist weg können
sie mir sagen wie dieses wort
ausgesprochen wird der berg der berg der
berg der berg ist hoch
der könig der könig der könig
der könig das ding ist richtig aber der
könig war lustig und sagte der berg muss
weg lustig lustig der teig der teig der
teig muss ziehen wenig wenig das ist
wenig geld
richtig gehen
ge hen gehen
ich gehe die straße entlang ich gehe mit
delphi ins kino wir gucken einen film
gucken gucken gucken also mit gucken
ich gucke gerade die schuhe an und 20 20
20 20 20 28 mag für mich wie ihr an den
beispielen seht gibt es leichte
variationen wie man das geht im
deutschen aussprechen kann es gibt
sowohl das weiche gege es gibt aber auch
ein hartes geht das fast wie das chaos
gesprochen wird
und es gibt eine variation die fast wie
ein ch ausgesprochen wird besonders
deutlich wird das bei wörtern die
aufliegenden und die auch in
verschiedenen regionen in deutschland
unterschiedlich ausgesprochen werden
es gibt ein projekt das heißt der atlas
zur deutschen alltagssprache das von der
universität salzburg und der universität
delhi gegründet wurde und dort wurden
unter anderem diese wörter untersucht
und hier seht ihr mal ein beispiel für
das wort 20 das in fast ganz nord- und
deutschland 20 gesprochen wird und in
einigen regionen in west und
ostdeutschland 20 und in süddeutschland
20 sagt sagt sagt
sie sagt guten morgen fertig fertig
fertig fertig fertig dass interviews
fertig danke das war unser kurzes video
für heute wir hoffen es hat euch
geholfen ein bisschen die aussprache zu
trainieren und die unterschiedlichen
aussprachen von gc zu hören
das ist ganz wichtig dass sie auch ein
bisschen diese aussprache übt und ihr
könnt natürlich mit uns jede woche üben
wenn ihre bachelor werde da könnt ihr
einfach hier draufklicken dann bekommt
ihr online übungen jede woche zu unserem
vokabular und zu den ausdrücken die wir
benutzen und ihr solltet unbedingt easy
german abonnieren das geht zum beispiel
hier und dann bekommt ihr jede woche
nachrichten über neue videos von uns
danke dass ihr da wart und viel spaß
euch noch in berlin
bis bald